[Music]
one of the topics that we think is
really interesting is what happens when
CEOs take a very controversial but
personal position on topics related to
the environment and our society or even
political and it gets a lot of attention
and you know customers and employees see
this and it can have some either
positive or negative consequences on the
company we're finding it's about yeah
maybe ten percent or even less of the
CEOs are engaging in activism in one
form or another so it's not like it's
everybody doing it but the ones that are
doing it tend to be very well known very
popular
you know sometimes founders sometimes
people that just have had a visionary
impact on the corporation
the types of things we're interested in
or activism by the CEO along things that
reflect their personal view we're not
talking about positions that the CEO
takes that you could imagine the
position being taken is one that makes
the the company better off something
like immigration visas for engineers you
can imagine companies that are tech
companies that's a really good thing and
they may be controversial but it's
really something that would be helped
them as a company so one thing that's
interesting based on our surveys is
there's certain topics that society
seems to want people away on and other
other topics not so topics like health
care clean energy environment seem to be
very very popular but things like
abortion religion politics things like
that they tend to want the CEOs to stay
out of that so something like I think we
all agree is really important to talk
about is gun control you know it's a
super controversial area especially
depending on what part of the country
you're from and so you know do you want
to take a take a stance or potentially
fund some initiative on gun control well
you know you're gonna have a lot of
employees and customers that'll find
that to be a good thing and others that
we're finding out to be something you
gotta really stay out of
so CEOs are much more visible there's a
lot more eyes on them so when CEOs are
activists so they take a very personal
position on a controversial topic it
shows up almost immediately there's a
velocity of social media such that you
could go from nothing to something
pretty serious in a matter of you know
minutes or hours and you know that can
explode either in good ways or bad ways
if you take a position that most
customers don't agree with I mean you
could lose sales or if you take a
position that's not consistent with what
employees want you can you could have a
hard time attracting and retaining
employees one of the things we're doing
now is taking a look at what happens to
sales and purchases of companies
typically in a retail space but where
CEOs taken a very strong position on a
controversial topic you know did the
sales go up or down things like that if
you take a stance on something you know
you could start you know doing some
arithmetic where you know what customers
might we lose or what customers might we
gain by doing these things same thing on
the employee side you know there are
some employees and be turned off by this
and maybe leave and others would be
attracted to it the flip side of it is
that we've done some surveys which find
is that about you know two-thirds of the
people want to CEOs take a leadership
position somebody's controversial
environmental social issues it varies a
bit depending on your political
affiliation or you know what generation
you're in whether you're a Boomer Gen X
or millennial or whatever but the costs
and benefits are something you want to
think about you know it's hard to
quantify but it may be the case that
cameras are willing to you know maybe
take a hit in terms of the economics but
actually do something you know really
good for the environment or other
stakeholders one thing we find in the in
the research is some early indications
that consumers are willing to buy more
from companies that take that activist
position on positions that they agree
with we find the flip side as well that
they're likely to buy less from
companies that take activist position on
something that they disagree with so I
mean these positions can you know shift
you know customer purchases in all the
way you know it affects the bottom line
of the company
the one thing I think is really key is
that the board in the government
structure of the organization have to
anticipate these things and they want to
talk about it ahead of time and not be
blindsided and I think the smart boards
are actually kind of going through a bit
of scenarios where what would we do if I
think the boards really need to think
about do they want the CEO you know
making personal statements about these
things or not and you know what pushback
might be well it's the CEO saying and
it's his personal opinion or her
personal opinion but you know really
it's hard to separate the CEO of the
company as a person from the company
itself so that could either be a good
thing or a bad thing you want to put
kind of constraints on them you know
kind of lay that out in a formal way and
then if you take these positions you
know you might want to think about
what's the cost of benefits of doing
that for shareholders so it's it's
complicated
so the role the board is is tricky and
it's evolving especially now companies
have historically been in the u.s. at
least focused on shareholder value more
recently some of the big institutional
investor is like Larry Fink at Blackrock
have sent letters out to boards saying
hey you have to take these other
stakeholders into account customers
employees the society environment and
even the government so I mean there's
push to sort of change from a strict
shareholder focus and that kind of
setting you can imagine CEOs advocating
certain positions that the view is
better for society and kind of embrace
the stakeholder views where it's like
let's really start paying serious
attention to the environment or
workplace diversity or things like that
so I think it's gonna be interesting to
see how the boards focus changes and I
think it's gonna be interesting to see
how aisle CEOs respond but it's a it's a
it's an evolution
you can imagine at some point people
demanding you know here are these topics
that we feel strongly about as customers
and employees what is your stance you
know on this kind of this kind of thing
there's a lot of things that are would
probably make you know the environment
better off that are very costly you know
where you know the the value to
shareholders is probably not positive
that's that's where it becomes very very
complicated are you willing to make
those investments because just the right
thing to do for for those stakeholders
and I think that whole thing has to be
mapped out it's certainly a lot more
discussion about stakeholder interest
now you know people investing in
environmental social and governance
sorts of funds you know more money
pouring into that you know that type of
thing you can have a whole new
generation of board members that are
that you know sort of understand this
stuff grew up with it and I think it's
going to change the discussion they'll
be interested to see how that plays out
going forward
you
[Music]